let's talk about the big change in the
big funny news we got the story from
business insider
moderna bioentech and novavax plunge
after biden says the covet 19 pandemic
is over
whoops yeah who what where are those put
options at who's waiting for this moment
congress members
paul pelosi the reason why they waited
five days to air it is because they had
a call all they were like hey everyone
probably dan crenshaw sell your stocks
absolutely
i mean yeah because those folks knew
this was
this is an important story the new york
times did actually a good job they
investigated uh the the inves the
investments of congress members and they
reported out of 3 700 trades they made
over a hundred million dollars with many
of them with uh being almost perfectly
timed so the new york times actually did
a good job investigated and showed the
insider trading that is absolutely too
good to be true for a lot of these
representatives this congress that got
rich off of these stocks this aired
september 18th and it was filmed when he
went there which was on tuesday so we
need to investigate who sold stocks
between september 13th and september
18th
especially these three or any of the
pharmaceutical companies and it would be
fascinating to then have a legit
investigation to say congressman
crenshaw how did you know to sell all of
your moderna on friday before the market
is closed we don't know we actually
didn't
just usually just be using a name
congressman turner i'll call myself oh
there's a congressman turner congressman
how did you know to buy all that bacon
how did how did you know that would be a
fascinating study because someone made
money i'm willing to bet you'll find a
lot of people so what i would imagine
would have happened is that cbs probably
did something they mentioned in the
interview they contacted the white house
for comment
remember that right when biden when
biden mentioned that we would intervene
for taiwan and we'll get to get to that
in a bit they said
in the video they released after biden
gave this response we reached out to the
white house who said the policy is not
changed despite the commander-in-chief
saying it did which means
they did the interview
they then called politicians for
comments edited the interview then put
it up
how much you want to bet after he's at
the pandemic was over they they called
all it takes is one member of congress
they call pelosi like what do you think
about this as the speaker and she went
oh is that what he said i'll call you
back and then she's like honey you need
to show all of this facts before he get
the interview comes out and then paul
does it and then everyone watching the
nancy pelosi stock tracker sees it yeah
it's down 10 from the 16th to the 8th to
the 19th
uh moderna okay since they announced
well that's the one that pelosi graphics
card uh that was the company with the
pelosi the pelosi trading one yes that
one also when they sold it off was also
at a very good time because the stock
went down there was another piece of
news that came out against nvidia which
you were describing before which i
thought ian was talking about yeah that
he sold surprisingly he knew to sell
right right before this exactly people
were saying he only sold uh because he
wanted to be ethical and wanted to come
clean but but he actually sold on a good
time which actually gave them even more
money but what you guys understand too
is we often talk about how it's insider
trading because they know when to sell
right how often do they propose the
bills themselves to shift the market
like
you could have you know a new computer
chip and then they're like this new
computer can be bad for my stock let's
put a bill forward that will stop it and
give some bs reasons yeah or how often
is like hey i just bought a whole bunch
of ben and jerry's stock where i guess
what is that unilever and uh i wanted to
go up so we're gonna do the tax ice
cream tax break stock that would be
intentionally pushing a bill forward to
make their stocks go up absolutely
really definitionally fascist they
probably do it all the time it should be
felonious yeah i know but that's but how
can you prove it well the new york times
actually found out that it was the
committee members using their position
on the committees in congress that voted
on particular aspects that changed the
business landscape that were enriching
themselves the most look at the
inflation reduction act that we just
passed and 386 billion dollars goes
towards the investment in green tech did
anyone who voted for that in committee
and who appropriated that number do they
have a stock in any of these green
companies do they have stock in
in sharepoint which makes electric
charges do they have stock in in ge
which makes a lot of our wind turbines i
mean it's just if you're going to spend
386 billion dollars someone is going to
make a lot of money off of that and
didn't they make a bunch of money off
the pharmaceutical companies like
absolutely
sure the pharmaceutical industry created
more billionaires than any other
industry within the last few years but i
mean like what weren't there like a
bunch of was a big controversy wasn't it
a bunch of members of congress
sold their stocks right before kovic
richard burr is senator from north
carolina that's why he's not running
again right now you got to look at
modernist stock in april of 2020 it was
28
in april of 21 145
so up eight seven seven times and then
it was four hundred and fifty dollars
six months later so i mean that's what
is that a 20 times increase in like a
year and a half this makes me angry you
know why because i didn't buy it
richard burr from north carolina i used
to turn it to 400 bucks richard from
north carolina was the one who was
probably hit the hardest on that i
forget who the democrat was but he was
he's the republican he's not running for
re-elect right now he probably could
have and would have sailed but for this
but he was one of the ones that they
said you had in a skiff which only no
secure compartmentalized you know secret
room to have these confidential meetings
in a skiff you had this briefing that
same day you bought all the you made all
these purchases and all these sales
and just like i you know what so what's
the charge and he just played innocent
and some people and people like you luke
made a big deal out of it and then he
decided well i'm not gonna run for
re-election next year but there are a
lot of senators who can point to the
timeline and say you were in this
confidential briefing and you either
sold in time because remember this is
this is february of 2019 the market the
20th of february of 2020 the markets
were roaring and it's like but suddenly
the markets are exploding and you sold
everything five million dollars worth of
stock and the doj drops their
investigation into all these people
which is absolutely crazy and they and
they start investigating trump
supporters yeah look
actually i
i think it was fairly obvious the
vaccines were were gonna
just skyrocket and stock value but you
have to be someone who's
not only in the know newswise you have
to have the money and you have to be
knowledgeable in this market space so
even though we all were tracking the
news and knew about the vaccines and
stuff i'm not a day trader i don't know
well that's why rand paul is always
beating up fauci to say why don't you
have to disclose your royalties and the
answer is senator we don't have to
disclose that and i don't have to tell
you
where to miss yes and rand paul is like
you don't have to disclose to congress
what your royalties are so you know who
in the cdc made a lot of money off of
this because they knew when they were
going to approve a vaccine if you're if
you're a tim pool vaccine approver and
you're like we're going to give these
guys the green green light on friday hmm
maybe do you buy some stock on three and
when you see it hit its top these stocks
they rocketed to like 20 times their
value in march of 21 and then within
like
20 days they just plummeted so somebody
was holding some people and they made 20
times their investment and then just
sold out on the market and what's great
is that they dropped them they bought it
back up what cracks me up is that the
members of congress who do this then
hauled that guy martin
shkarelli
pharma bro and they were like how dare
you how dare you look at yourself and
i'm like you should have been like have
you all looked in a mirror how much do
you guys made during the covid pandemic
jam it's a shame oh it's absurd it's
just it's criminal it's it's god they'll
tell you that that's the whole reason
they run for office about a lot of
people they're like you get in you get
some insider trading you get out you're
rich for life paul pelosi and and some
members of congress uh they're better
stock pickers than warren buffett they
are why would they work on wall street
yeah go go work for an investment house
i mean you're that good and if you have
an account on social media that that
documents all the trades and and gives
the the peasants
advice you get censored your accounts
get taken down which has happened to a
number of individuals that literally
created accounts about the the trading
of nancy pelosi which has a better track
record than all the other big stock guys
out there better than warren buffett
better than all the top guys that you
could even imagine in this field how's
that possible yeah it's amazing uh shout
out to my homies at rumble they just
went public today tim told me earlier
and uh
i bought rumble stock i'm not an
investment manager
so it was a spac acquisition
cfvi i think merged with rumble and now
they're trading under are you in well
was i don't play inside
games i'm just letting everyone know
ahead of time i did buy some of that
because i have faith in the future of
rumble how about a bunch yeah i don't
know if that's necessary to disclose at
all basketball of rumble stuff i think
there's nowhere to go but literally like
right before the show i was just like
yeah it's the future chris pavlovsky
knows what he's well he's got a lot of
good good ideas and i'm i'm really
excited to see what they do i mean and
or local gaming too i'll put it this way
i'll put it this way um you know we we
we're in the know when it came to what
was going on the news and we saw the
vaccines were coming we knew who was
making them and i don't think anybody
here bought any stock in those companies
no no and i don't think i would have
early no hell no no i bought stock in
palantir and i didn't know much about it
but my body was like it's about to
skyrocket so i bought it and then it
went up times 10 and i sold it all i
remember i i sold all of my um
airline stocks when i was i was doing
the tv show kennedy on fox the night
president trump announced that he was
banning air traffic from europe and i
remember thinking i'm gonna sell all my
airlines because i just had a feeling
this was going in the wrong direction
and so like yeah so i made a great
decision but but i probably was
three days late i'm sure that a lot of
people who were in that confidential
meeting they sold their airlines
before this is what i wanted to say
about the modern stuff is
were in the know on the news yet we
didn't buy any of that stuff we're in
the know on big tax censorship and
social media and now rumble is trading i
think at like 16 bucks so that's my
attitude was like i i think it's it's i
don't know if it spikes like 400
anything crazy like that because it's
not a mandated vaccine or anything but i
i bought a bunch because i think it'll
go up yeah it's a company i believe in
that's why i bought it yeah i don't i
don't like one of the things about
finance that i really don't like is that
you kind of need to set your morals and
ethics aside if you want to make money
and you just know if the war machine's
going on that
raytheon is my man for now and then i'm
going to sell it and buy pfizer and then
i'm out of there i'm going to buy some
oil and fracking i was going to say
because i'm programmed to hate this
stuff but hey check someone check check
the stock on like raytheon or lockheed
when the ukraine war started what
february yeah but i bet it spiked right
sure it did but it probably it probably
doesn't have as much room to grow
because it's already a massive you know
military-industrial when did we go hot
in in ukraine oh yeah
that's exactly right tim it went from at
the end of december it was 82 bucks
as 102 by march so up up 20 what's it at
now right now it's sitting at about 80.
let's come down a little bit
but when the war starts but that's what
was that raytheon yeah yeah but are we
using what about boeing or like lockheed
martin what's another was it was another
one
north of grumman north of grumman
you know all the military i thought
about that boeing's actually been up and
down and then dropped in may
boeing's biggest moneymaker is uh
airlines airplanes right and the
airplane industry is just getting
crushed but they're doing that oh that's
probably why even if they make drones or
whatever we also have to understand
normal northrop exploded in march it
went from 369 to 450. 180. how many
billions have we given them and and war
and uh you know warheads wow and it's
just gone up since then it's at 485 now
wow who should we declare war on next
right to get more money
i don't care who just let me know but in
advance
that's all it matters
but but you again you won't have an
advantage like the politicians have and
normal people when they do insider
trading they get arrested they face real
prosecution they face the the justice
system going down breathing down their
necks and putting them in jail going
down i was like where are you going
martha's right here get your hand out of
there martha stewart headed out of the
gutter
she was worth
she's a billionaire she went to jail for
six months absolutely 75 000 trade yeah
why aren't these congress members why
aren't these senators
for their insider trading and then we
also have to understand how nasty this
is especially when it comes to so many
people struggling financially this is
this is a game there's winners and
there's losers they rigged the system so
they are always the winners who's the
losers everyone else all the other
peasants the people who have their
retirements accounts in the stock market
that of course are guaranteed to lose
because these people are rigging the
game for the benefit of themselves so so
this is absolutely seedy disgusting
behavior especially when it comes to so
many people being poor so many blue
collar workers being screwed over and
these people are enriching themselves
while taking money away from everyone
else do you think the lottery is like
unethical uh yeah because most of that
money goes to the state and it's and
it's taxed and uh absolutely yeah
i i think yeah they tax like what like
half almost almost half of it so you're
you're literally financing the state
through the lottery it's just legalizing
it they call it a poor tax yeah it's
gambling and then you know if 100 bucks
go into the pot 50 bucks goes to the
government the 50 bucks goes to the jack
you know the jackpot and then you pay
taxes on that even yeah like the person
who won the 1.2 billion dollars who
still doesn't come forward which is odd
um i think they were taking home at the
end of the day like 400 million which is
nothing to sneeze at but basically
government stole 800 million dollars
from that person but then you got to pay
taxes so it's like it's not only is the
is the is the pot split between the
person and the government's cut but then
the the money you get actually gets cut
again yeah it's funny how that works so
of the 1.2 was 2.4 half of it had gone
to the government and they're getting
taxed another 60 or 70. that's why they
were walking away with 400 million
because 1.2 right off the bat you know
um half of it goes to education and then
you have half and then your half gets
cut in half by taxes i don't like like
saying like this should be illegal this
should be illegal but that lottery has
really always set me really really
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you